hi my name is Joel grindz I'm from
s-someone and recorded nights from
Peckham so down we'll be talking about
the x-men and why that's important to me
so the x-men are a mutant team who came
together to make a difference within the
mutant world they're led by one the
greatest x-men called professor X he
brought them together he trained them
because they're mutants the human world
did not understand them they had powers
they had abilities they're not they're
not dangerous because they're different
because people don't understand them but
a lot of people fear them because they
don't understand them as a man who grew
up in a black man who grew up in Peckham
South London an area that was proclaimed
to be dangerous wherever I went within
the country
I was assumed to be dangerous a friend
so those things related to me as the
x-men they took a hard route they took a
lot of people throwing rubbish at them
and speaking horribly about them on the
news even though a lot of the stuff they
everything he was doing was for a
positive course and they took that route
they took that route and then later on
the President of the United States thank
them for a lot of things it made me
believe that if them x-men who was such
a great force who people respect it can
go through all this that pain and and a
lot of people giving them a lot of
negative feedback on where they're doing
good in everything if they can go
through these things and I can go
through things as a black man I can take
all this pain and still do good and
still do positive stuff and then later
on be accepted for the great things that
I do
[Music]
professor Eck's my lifting
he believed that mutants and humans
could live one that they could be equal
they could be fine they could live in a
world together where magneto where order
pain a lot of mutants had been had gone
through because the humans who did not
understand them yet know there were two
people who stood for the same results
except for they believed that to make
this happen
it had to happen in two different ways
and as a man who grew up in these kind
of things like I thought wow this is
this is amazing that they're putting
this in in comic books they're put in my
history which we wasn't taught in school
when you're young you don't spend so
much time with your parents because your
parents are at work and so you wasn't
taught these things so I'm reading and
I'm learning them understanding more
black history for a comic book and that
meant a lot to me
you